foreign
the legal part I like the more I learn
about the legal part like like get it
signed by the state I'd like to have
like I don't know I think about this
because I have mixed feelings because I
understand why guys yeah I understand
why guys don't want to get married
okay but I feel like as a girl like if
you have kids like you want to have like
some you go this is the switch up now
some level of commitment but I think
like I was thinking about it I think I'd
be cool to just like some sort of
ceremony or something without the state
I don't know I have to think
look women gonna switch hey guys women
gonna switch up on you bro so typically
this is what I tell guys once whatever
she says
before the marriage ring and the kids is
not what she's going to say when the
marriage ring and the kids come
yeah they she turns into a different
woman because of naturally she wants to
have the kids survive everything she
does is for those kids and every every
bit of love she thought she knew
is doesn't compare to the love she has
for that kid and the kid has for her so
she might this is what I told me don't
listen to what women think of love
because it ain't even a love yet when
she experienced childbirth and she she
has kids that's the love and then she's
gonna have a different priority so you
might say you don't want to stay from
the marriage but then when you have kids
you're gonna be like well how are these
kids are going to survive if I get
divorced you're going to have a
different mindset that's it what do you
think for your so you're it's
interesting so you have a daughter do
you think she should get married I have
a son too yeah so yeah but if someone
asked me this question right and I said
about a daughter I'd say that's the son
I'd say no oh so I see what you said
well this is typical because you want
the daughter to be taken care of right
right
like I just feel like there's like a
level of commitment once you get married
like I think it's better for kids to be
in a two-parent household but it's like
even today it's so easy to get divorced
so what do we do that's what that's my
whole point is again these marriages are
temporary they're very temporary so
they're like do you want your daughter
to get married do I wanted to get
divorced because that's coming that's
going to likely come so do I want to see
my daughter hurt in that manner to get
divorced
[Music]
Ure
oh well if she got divorced because she
left most likely yeah but there yeah so
do I want when women get divorced
they are putting themselves in a
position that is going to be detrimental
to them long term
getting married in divorced that's like
that's like the clock swag midnight your
life is going to be forever tainted yeah
now she gonna try to patch it up and
they act like she living her best life
but when she in the kitchen having
dinner with her dog and then eventually
when she gets old enough where she
eating the dog food and then when
there's no more dog food she eating the
dog yeah yeah so is your answer no then
or yes
oh by the time how old is she she's 16.
oh she's 16. yeah so you think marriage
what do you think of the data set that
women between the ages of 18 the women
that get married before the age of 25
have higher divorce rates
I've heard that I've heard the opposite
too yeah I think it's below it might be
below 22 or 21 like the young the young
people get divorced and I've actually
heard the longer you wait wait the the
more uh
right right
so the the one the data the data I've
seen it's like between 25 and 30 is the
longest lasting ones I'm just curious
yeah and I'm just wondering if we're
gonna say the same thing as I the reason
I think
um here's the here's the secret okay
okay
um a successful marriage is in a
marriage that stays intact I'll repeat
it a successful marriage isn't a
marriage that stays intact a successful
marriage is a successful marriage so
just because two people stay together
typically when you get married older
you're basically a little more wiser
you're like I don't have any more
options I got married to push these kids
out in 2.5 years right so you're on a
speed up clock and you get married and
you're like all right I'm gonna make
this work right I don't want to go back
out there dating so you're gonna stick
you're going to stick together some of
these marriages are miserable behind
closed doors they so people say because
you stay together
I mean I wouldn't say success but I just
like how else would you measure good
versus bad you measure it when one or
both people dead and they're still
together that's marriage what do they
say in marriage what do they say in
marriage exactly so that's when you
judge the marriage
did they stay together until they did
yeah yep success so but what I was gonna
say with them they should be screwing
each other
the the before the the and I'm
butchering it so I know I know I'm not
saying it right but I know there's like
some study and I know it's like credible
okay before the age it's like people
that get married before a certain age
are more likely like they're the most
likely to get divorced I think it's
because the women today like The Virgins
today are not the virgins of yesterday
and it's like even if they're virgins
which is like the ideal they still hear
the whole stories and they might feel
like they missed out and then they might
divorce their husband before the party
that's right so that's typically like 32
they like oh I miss my younger years
yeah
that's common that's common actually my
ex-wife said that when we were again she
was like I miss out on my younger years
because I think she was 25 when I'm
married right so she he she
intentionally her intention was to have
a family and a husband
but as I said women are going to change
their mind and once he got that she was
like well I already got that so I'm
gonna go out there go back and party
because I missed it now what
so I'm sitting there like what happened
to my wife yeah and that's that's the
the kind of that's why I think you're
right with the rolling the dice because
it seems like you could get the quote
unquote like perfect girl she could be a
virgin but even like I I had um a show
on virgins like virgins versus hoes
something like that and you know
obviously like the Virgin is better but
the one comment that I kept getting is
like I dated a virgin but then she got
curious and laughed dude you're right
yeah you're right I always tell guys
they're like they're they're like there
needs to be more versions but the the
trick with the virgins is that they once
they're with you they're gonna wonder
what if
uh Mr excitement I want to go out there
so that's no guarantee
that's no good that that doesn't protect
you because there's still nightclubs and
Instagram and and that's and that's why
it's almost like men really don't want
to get married because it's like before
at least they got loyalty they got yeah
and now it's like nothing right yeah I
think the marketplace is that women have
just too many options and when you you
study people who have too much options
choices
foreign
unless you're over 50.
and that's where they get manipulated
they consider sexual attention
relationships yeah because of sex
anything anything anything
well because it's not about the person
it's about the ACT we're just trying to
feel I feel good yeah like I even had
guys on my show I was like how many of
you have had sex with a girl that you
were embarrassed yourself
she had like 80 of people's rotation is
busted Pillsbury biscuit can but that
shouldn't be seen as a negative
biologically we're able to spread our
seed so we're we're just trying to feel
good and you know it's an advantage that
we have
so people want to count it as a negative
that guys will screw anything but just
think about it there's a lot of ugly ass
people here and babies need to be had
so somebody got a screw somebody's
screwing them somebody's ruin these
donkeys you like who screwed that ass
donkey ass moose and she running around
with three babies
so if most of the people are ugly by by
definition bell-shaped curve there's a
small percent of Attractive people and
there's some ugly [ __ ] people and
everybody in the middle is average
that means there's eight billion people
on the earth almost 8 billion a lot of
ugly and average ass people got screwed
and Pregnant
so looks are almost inconsequential
especially if the guy don't have much
choice that's the other thing is
average is an insult right the average
at best thing no even just in the
nanosphere like people people say oh
she's average oh my God most people are
just fine I don't mind being average
I'll be right average I know I ain't all
that so I look at it like as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible